>> First things first, we need to distribute this multiplication by five to both
the x and the negative two. Since in slope intercept form, y is all by itself on
the left side of the equation, we're going to need to move this negative three
term out of the left side. So we add three to both sides, since right now it's
being subtracted. And we end up with a final equation of y equals five x minus
seven. So, this equation. In our earlier equation should be equivalent or rather
these should be equations that graph exactly the same line. To make sure that
this equation fits the information that we used to create the equation end
points slope form, let's see if the point we started are with lies on this line.
We can already tell that the slope of this line is 5. So that gets rid of one of
our criteria. let's check each side of this equation done with the point 2, 3.
One the left hand side we have y, and substituting in our value for y, we have
3. So the left hand side gives us 3. Now what about the right hand side? The
expression on the right hand side of the equation is 5x minus 7. Let's see what
that is equivalent to when we plug in our point. So you substitute 2 in for x.
And for this side of the equation we also end up with 3. Since our left hand
side and our right hand side match each other, we plug in our information. We're
good to go. We have confirmed that this equation fits our information.